extranjero
[Risas]
[Música]
bueno, probablemente haya la peor
inundación que he visto aquí desde que
vivo aquí desde 1984. Aptos Creek
estaba disminuyendo la velocidad con tanta furia que pensé que
iba a arrancar a nuestro pequeño
peatón  pasarela y eran troncos de árboles que
se empujaban río abajo casi a una
velocidad de aproximadamente uno cada 30 segundos.
Fue increíble ver la cantidad de
escombros y madera que bajaba por
el arroyo
extranjero.
Sí, es bastante devastador. Me siento mal.
No lo creo.  partes de esta ciudad
alguna vez se recuperarán, será diferente,
sabes que Capital Village es solo donde, quiero
decir, los restaurantes a los que solíamos ir
todo el tiempo estaban cubiertos de algas y
arena, es bastante triste,
pero solo tomará tiempo
[  Música]
estaremos asombrados para decirte la
verdad como yo y que sabes que
seguimos mejorando los sistemas meteorológicos.
Estoy como cuánto más podemos manejar, así que
lo estoy viendo desde el frente hacia abajo.
aquí como debajo del nivel del mar que es simplemente
alucinante
[Música]
extranjero